let's talk a little bit about the people
who buy eggs so how much do they
typically pay is there a big markup as
big as in the sperm side what do we know
about those people how they select how
they pay those kinds of questions again
egg agencies are not unlike sperm banks
where they want a diverse array of
donors to satisfy any recipient who may
walk in the door or click on the website
so they're looking for women of various
racial and ethnic backgrounds people of
different majors different life
experiences and recipients will
typically pay they're paying for their
own in vitro fertilization cycle they're
paying for all the doctors and lawyers
and psychologists who are involved in
this process the egg donor fee is tacked
on to that so whatever negotiated fee is
decided for that egg donor based on how
many times she's cycled sometimes her
educational background sometimes her
racial or ethnic category so again here
egg donation looks very different from
sperm banks in that there is a
negotiated price for that particular
donor whereas most sperm banks will
really have a price that they assign to
all the donors in the bank that's
interesting and in terms of what women
look for in egg donors is it different
from what they look for in sperm donors
that is a great research question I have
not seen somebody do that study write
something another dissertation top if
you're watching here you're a graduate
student we're giving you dissertation
topics so we talked a little bit about
the difference between anonymous versus
open sperm donation can you tell us a
little bit how it plays out differently
if at all in the egg world so again an
interesting distinction is that sperm
banks have these formalized identity
release programs egg agencies do not sow
egg agencies have a much shorter history
the first ones were started in the late
80s early 90s and they were just much
less focused on anonymity and secrecy so
to this day you'll go to an egg agency
and you'll find a woman's adult photo
with her first name sometimes her last
initial so there's just much less
emphasis on secrecy and typically egg
agencies were also more comfortable with
donors and recipients being in touch it
didn't happen
you know in the majority of cases but it
was a possibility where it was never
allowed in sperm banks so one of the
arguments I make in the book is that
sperm banks have formalized this process
in which it's possible for offspring to
come back
meet the donor and again I think that's
because we think of the paternal line as
somehow more significant than the
maternal line
we haven't instantiated any formal
processes for offspring to meet their
egg donors and so I think that raises
interesting contrast in terms of how we
think of progenitors that's really
interesting opportunity versus maternity
are there any differences in the
attitudes of the people the ultimate
recipients so women who use egg donation
versus women who use sperm donation
their openness is there more of a
feeling of being replaced if you're a
woman who's had to use another egg and
the child meets that person as opposed
to a man who's had to use a sperm donor
is the other way around yeah so there's
a whole interesting series of studies
being done by Susan Gillum Bach at
Cambridge University and she has a group
of postdocs and grad students who are
doing fascinating work with just this
question in mind not only for the
recipients how do a gross if Ian's
versus sperm recipients think about that
donation but also for the children how
do offspring of egg donors versus
offspring of sperm donors think about
those relationships so we'll await the
results of those studies and again on
this line of paternity versus maternity
is there a difference in the way in
which a sperm donor versus an egg donor
thinks about their role in the family
structure yeah this is actually one of
the most surprising things that I found
in my book
in talking with egg donors and sperm
donors about how they think about the
children who are out there in the world
sperm donors to a person had the idea
that they were the fathers of those
children they would use kinship language
they would say well they may not have my
last name but those are my children
they're my parents grandchildren when I
have children they're going to be their
siblings so they thought of themselves
as fathers and egg donors who have the
exact same biogenetic relationship right
they've provided half the genetic
material to create that embryo that
child egg donors were adamant that they
were not mothers and they would say
things they use this phrase just an egg
all I gave was just an egg somebody else
was pregnant somebody else gave birth
somebody else is raising that child so
for women they're really able to
partition reproduction into stages and
say well all I gave was just this little
one part so I'm not the mother
surrogates interestingly do the same
thing surrogates say all I gave was just
the pregnancy
I didn't provide the egg I'm not raising
the child so I'm not the mother and this
again I think points to broader cultural
norms around maternity and paternity
such that we don't have that same
ability to partition fatherhood you
can't say all I gave was just a sperm
I'm not the dad because we have a
cultural equation in which providing the
sperm makes you a dad and so here it's
interesting to me that our definitions
of motherhood in some ways are much more
flexible than our definitions of
fatherhood and this is interesting in
some ways because the setup of the sperm
banks versus the egg agencies would lead
you to think the opposite right the more
it seems like shift work I'm doing this
three times or twice a week every week
great less I would think of myself as a
father to all these children right but
it seems as though this gendered
conception of fatherhood because there's
only one way to become a father give
sperm whereas with women there are these
two separate components seems like it
continues notwithstanding the setup of
the industry right well and I think the
stakes for women are high because if egg
donors were defined as mothers then they
would be mothers who give away their
babies for $5,000 and that would make
them terrible mothers so the sort of
cultural discussions that we have around
who is a good mother who is a good
father what makes a mother what makes a
father this really plays out in
interesting ways that as you say
militate against these ideas of who's
doing a job who's giving a gift but the
gift can't be you can't be too invested
in that gift right and what about the
international market for eggs how is
that look different so this is changing
as we speak there is a burgeoning market
in countries like India and Spain where
people can now travel in order to get
reproductive services for less money
than they would pay in the United States
and so we're just starting to see the
emergence of these networks of egg
donors and again because our ideas about
race and ethnicity get biologies we
expect those categories to be present at
the level of the eggs and the sperm then
people are going to countries and
looking for services in ways that match
their understandings of race and
ethnicity and lastly about the eggs I
want to just ask you about the
altruistic provision of eggs these are
people who donate who don't expect to be
paid what do we know about these women
how they're different from women who
sell their eggs so again this is a great
question the discussions around the
sperm donors online have
a lot of attention I haven't seen as
many online advertisements for women
providing their eggs I think the
altruistic egg donation altruistic is a
term that I talk about a lot in my book
so I'll say non-paid egg donation I
think I just unpack that first yes why
the discomfort of using the term
altruistic it's because there are many
different motivations even for people
who are paid is that the main reason
well exactly I think the we have this
assumption that if you're paid it can't
be altruistic but when I interviewed egg
donors and sperm donors they were being
paid and yet they also felt that they
were helping people so part of what I
try to do in the book is collapse this
distinction that the world is not neat
and tidy where you know the altruist
soar over here and the paid folks are
over here and so I think when we look at
how people actually exist in the world
and how they think about that the money
that they're paid it causes us to
question those categories great now in
fact now too
unpaid better term than altruistic
unpaid egg providers you're gonna say
something about them yeah so I think
that where I've heard people talk about
egg donors who aren't paid it typically
is people's friends or sisters or
cousins who might be willing to provide
them an egg in order to reduce the costs
of their egg donation expenses within
family donation I've also heard reports
of it happening in sperm donors I don't
know that I've seen a systematic study
of these kinds of experiences but the
questions that people raise are if
you're getting genetic material from
somebody in your own family how is that
going to then shape the family dynamics
going forward and are people going to
treat each other differently how is the
child gonna think about who its parent
is so those are some of the questions
that get raised with unpaid within
family donation right so the idea that
you might be both genetic mother and
sociological and/or family and writing
how to kind of put those two together is
fascinating and I would say that this is
more of a concern for same-sex couples
like lesbian couples so because lesbians
don't have some of the same protections
in law in terms of their relationships
with their children a lot of lesbians do
get and rightly get very nervous about
having a friend provide sperm and so
often you'll see lesbian couples go to
sperm banks with somebody they know the
person donates through the sperm bank
and that's providing them some legal
protection for their relationships with
their child
so that the man can't come back later
and say oh yeah I actually wanted to be
the father and later in the course we'll
actually talk about how some of the
statutes say that if you have
insemination done by a licensed
physician it's treated differently than
if it's done at home for example and
exactly the way you say precisely Renee
you've studied this market very
intensely there's one or two things you
could change if you had a magic wall and
it can waive it and change something
what would you change if I could wave a
magic wand and make changes in this
market I think the thing is that we
could do better we could collect some
basic data about how many people are
involved in this market how many donors
how many recipients how many children
and sociologically I'd be fascinated to
know in more systematic ways about their
experiences of this market in terms of
kinship in terms of payment in terms of
employment in terms of donation I think
one of the things that we really need to
concentrate on is this issue of risk so
there are a lot of people who are going
through IVF treatments who are being egg
donors who are freezing their eggs we
need to know a lot more about the
biological and medical effects of those
reproductive technologies and then I
would say for sperm donors one of the
things that I walk away from this book
thinking is that we spend a lot of time
because of our cultural expectations of
women talking about egg donors and how
this is a really useful wonderful thing
that women are doing and I think sperm
banks could do a lot more to make this
less of a sort of seedy dirty funny
thing and have men think about what it
is that they're donating and have them
consider how they're gonna think about
it 10 years or 20 years down the line so
I think sperm banks could do better by
their donors and they're currently doing
right now thank you so much for joining
us once again the book is sex sells see
e LLS whether you're an academic or not
this is a great read and thank you for
sharing your time with us thank you so
much for having me